the Joe Rogan experience it's uh it's
one of those things then where it's like
I'm probably not gonna try to fix
something that's not broken Ryan you're
pretty diligent about your
supplementation yeah and I mean I I
definitely am Not Afraid to salt my food
you know most my food is conducive to
putting salt on so you know I'm probably
getting quite a bit of that stuff just
in my day of day-to-day nutrition - do
you have specific salt that you like to
use Himalayan do you see Saul like what
do you like to use yeah I like to get
sea salt lately I've been using uh this
stuff called Redmon's sea salt they they
get their salt at alike I believe it's
in Utah in Salt Lake okay and I don't
know like if the how accurate or
whatever this is but like they I heard
that if you can get an inland sea salt
it's better because it's not like it
doesn't have potential as many potential
toxins that you can find like oceans
yeah yeah that's what the idea about
Himalayan sea salt is right because it's
no real [ __ ] sea in the Himalaya is
it called Himalayan sea salt or am I
just making that up
or is it Himalayan salt I think it's sea
salt right yeah the pink Himalayan sea
salt right yeah but how was it
sea salt explained that how does that
work was it an older sea I wonder if
like it is and it's similar it's just
like these big salt oh it is just salt
okay oh it's just Himalayan salt No oh
yeah I think I've heard it like an old
sea that's no longer there and they just
have the big salt deposits right like
that's what a lot of Montana is the
Great Western in inland sea you know
like millions of years ago like they
find seashells in Montana yeah she was
just [ __ ] bonkers yeah it's crazy uh
I was I was in Utah earlier in the year
a camera where we were just out of Salt
Lake and apparently that used to be on
underwater too and like they'll find
like sharp teeth and stuff like that
around there like you're up on this like
trail and they're like there's no water
and say think about that next time you
see some [ __ ] that spend ten million
dollars on a house on the beach yeah you
think that's gonna stay there okay pay
for that event yeah that it's not gonna
be here something's gonna be different
in the future it's always been that way
like there's no permanent like a place
where the water is
the water isn't yeah it is funny how we
think of that though ever it's like you
see the map now and we're like oh okay
this is just how it is and yeah maybe
not well look at Pangaea yeah you know
things changed pretty goddamn
erratically what's up Jamie I don't know
the accuracy of this but I just found
this okay
Himalayan sea salt is a gourmet salt
with a slightly misleading name it
doesn't come from the Himalayan
mountains oh Jesus and it doesn't come
from a sea these [ __ ] it's
definitely a seesaw so it's not a total
misnomer Himalayan salt ashley refers to
exclusively to pakistani rock salt well
they used to be sea salt hundreds of
millions of years ago so why don't we
call it Pakistan if I was Pakistani I'd
be bass yeah like these [ __ ]
are stealing our shine when a sea
spreading over the region dried up it
was covered by geological shifts leaving
massive deposits of salts scattered
throughout the hills odd name aside
Himalayan salt has a lot going for it
it's tasty it's pink and some even claim
it as healing Prabhas [ __ ] healing
properties [ __ ] those are the people
that like crystals yeah we go that's
what we have a big Himalayan salt rock
right there
yeah will and low I'll just go like that
sucker has anybody looked at yet someone
must have licked it when were looking at
yeah I like Himalayan salt oats it does
it's nice but like for cooking like
we're cooking meat particularly I like
kosher salt because it's got the big big
flakes flakes yeah
what's the when when you put the big
flakes on there's that help like retain
the moisture on it or allegedly I don't
know
[Applause]